okay so Eamon Targaryen is probably my
favorite character in The House of the
Dragon storyline an almost perfect
opposite to Damon he's one of the most
cunning people in all of Westeros and I
thought I'd make a video discussing why
he's so important throughout this we're
going to be going over his backstory
what lies ahead with him and why we love
their character so much obviously full
spoilers ahead for the book so if you
don't want to know then you've gotta go
if you enjoy the video then please hit
the thumbs up button and also don't
forget to subscribe for breakdowns on
the series every week but out the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into house of the Dragon thank you
[Music]
now as we touched upon earlier Eamonn is
the perfect opposite to Damon on a
number of levels not only do their names
sound similar but their brothers also
end up becoming the king in the book
Alison puts together a plan to oustra
Nera after the death of viserys it looks
like the show is following the same
route this sets up the dynamic that both
Eamonn and Damon are very much opposites
to one another and throughout the
storyline we see as they become bitter
Rivals both are skilled Swordsmen
brilliant strategists and Eamonn stole
Damon's ex-wife's Dragon it just to add
some salt in the wound this creates a
heated rivalry between the two that will
discuss the outcome of later on in the
video and then going head-to-head was
teased at during the banquet and it
extends far beyond just being involved
in food fights as we've seen in the
series Eamonn was often overlooked when
he was younger and the book details how
when he was born he was half the size of
his brother aegon constantly pushed
around by him this created a fire within
him that slowly drove him to become more
and more ambitious whereas aegon had it
all handed to him on a plate Eamonn had
to fight for everything in his life and
this carved out an incredibly Fierce
character who would accomplish several
things in his childhood the books to
tell how he had trouble gaining a dragon
and when his family traveled to
driftmark his father said they'd then go
on to Dragonstone yeah he'd be given
either an egg or a recent hatchling
which wouldn't be difficult to tame he
was completely overlooked and Eamonn saw
this as a challenge and that night he
ended up traveling out to Vega Vega had
recently lost her Rider in Elena but no
one wanted to try tame her because of
how ferocious she was Hagar is often
referred to as the largest dragon in the
realm and getting this was a massive win
for Alice inside the series changes
things up from the book and in that he
was spotted by a young Joffrey who too
snuck out to see his Dragon he tried to
sound the alarm and snitch on him but
Eamonn kicked him into some Dragon
droppings before he took to the sky on
the back of bagar upon his return we had
what were going to become one of the
most defining moments in his life which
was the loss of his eye he called
runnier's kids trunks in this caused
luceris to slash it out rather than
being bitter over it though Eamonn
accepted that that day he lost an eye
but that he also gained a dragon badass
no else he didn't Harbor hey over this
he did however still hold a grudge
though this isn't stated in the book I
think this moment made Eamon realize
that he had to become a fighter in case
his situation like this happened again
userus was Far smaller and weaker than
he was but because he caught him off
guard he ended up losing an eye thus he
started train and the work states that
thanks to Kristen's help that he became
a proficient swordsman Eamon wore night
black armor that had Gold Lace
throughout it and he became a Stana
figure amongst the crowds he was a place
to sapphire stone in place of his
missing eye and when he was in court he
wore an eye patch to cover this however
when he went into battle he'd often
remove this in order to make himself
seem even more intimidating now viserys
ended up dying when he was 19 and after
his brother was chosen to become the
King the dance of the Dragons began the
two sides quickly scrambled to get power
her and they both sought out to take as
many houses as they could under their
dragon wings some would stay loyal to an
Era whilst others would fold under the
pressure from the greens and also their
beliefs that men should be the ones in
charge Eamonn was dispatched to Storm's
end to try and get Lord Boris to support
his brother and in exchange he said he'd
marry one of his daughters about lucerus
had been sent there too and like we saw
at the banquet he kept provoking him
laugh at me I tell you mate don't laugh
at the lad now the lad played a game of
around and find out and Eamon chasely
Sarah's in his Dragon RX after saying
that Luke owed him and I he and vegar
killed them both removed lucerus's eyes
and from that point he got the name kin
Slayer Alison was a bit like [ __ ] but
they're gonna end up throwing A Feast
for him as I'm sure you can imagine this
also didn't go down too well with the
Black Sea there and Damon's water an ear
out that there would be a sin for his
son we've seen throughout the series how
there's been this literal eye for an eye
mentality and also how this leads to
everyone losing their sight Damon ended
up using his mazaria connection and she
sent assassins to kill aegon Sunder
Harris they accomplished their goal and
it sent Helena mad which meant she could
no longer ride dragons the next big
event happened at the Battle of regress
and this saw Eamonn aegon and Kristen
teaming up with one another they
successfully managed to kill rhaenice
and her Dragon whether the battle came
with a cost and aegon was severely
wounded thus there was a spot on the
throne for someone to rule while stagon
recovered and Eamon took this up
smashing those promotion goals smashed
it now whereas Damon never got to sit on
the throne Eamonn saw over the realm and
as I'm shaking guess the guy was a G man
even mentioned how he thought he looked
better in the crown than his brother did
and he and Kristen ended up launching
several attacks this included one on
Harren Hall which they ended up taking
at this point sir Kristen Cole was the
hand of the king and after they took
over they had Simon strong killed this
shows why Eamonn was so important
because without him a lot of his
location Nations wouldn't have fell
under their control during this time
Eamonn also started sleeping with Alice
Rivers who he'd spared after taking
harrenhal it was a big win however it
did come with a loss too going there
left King's Landing open and Ranier and
Damon managed to take over that Eamonn
ended up launching a massive attack at
this point and on the back of vegar he
destroyed several locations owned by the
blacks man rained fire down on
everything turning a lot of their land
into Scorch death Aaron Hall was taken
back for a brief time during this but
Eamonn arrived once more saved the day
and took back his lover she eventually
ended up becoming pregnant and later in
the timeline this child would be
presented as the rightful heir to
replace egg on the younger what about
that's a video for another time and
during the campaign by aymond Damon was
desperate to take him out because he'd
seen how much he'd managed to cause
after going to Harren Hall Damon waited
for him for 13 days until Eamonn showed
up with his pregnant wife eventually the
pair took to the skies to do battle and
it's one of the most important moments
in both the characters lives that would
lead to their deaths as they Clash
together above the God's eye they start
a hurtling to a descent and Damon
stabbed Eamonn in the eye with his sore
dark sister the pair both crashed into
the body of water with Eamonn sinking
down into the lake due to being tied to
vagar he was recovered later on with
dark sister still embedded in his head
however it wasn't really a win for
anira's side either Eamonn seemingly
managed to kill Damon and though his
body was never recovered he never
emerged again the series might reveal
that Damon is still in fact alive but
either way Eamon managed to take him out
the dance of the Dragons because of this
rhaenyra lost her loyal protector and it
would become one of the key things that
made the story go the way it did though
Eamonn lived a relatively short life he
ended up becoming one of the most
important characters in Fire and Blood
due to how much he spun things in his
brother's favor early on in the timeline
he's a character who was often
overlooked but he overcame this
adversity and took out several key
players on runner's side died killing
his son was one of the most devastating
things that happened to an Era and it
made her realize that she needed a fight
on the same level at the green square
Eamonn Stands Strong he is one of the
most crucial characters in Game of
Thrones I often wonder what would have
happened if he'd been on the throne
instead and how King's Landing would
have fallen and then raniera couldn't
have take over and gotten such a
foothold there he's a fascinating
character to watch I think that the
series is doing a great job of bringing
him to life obviously I'd love to hear
your daughter name in so make sure you
comment below and let me know we are in
a competition right now and giving away
three copies of Thor and thunder on the
15th of October and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on drop a comment below
with your thoughts on the character you
pick the comments at random on the 15th
and the winners of the last one are on
screen right now say that to you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
we want some else to watch them make
sure you check out our Brighton of
episode 8 which will be linked on screen
right now we go over all the Easter eggs
in it the ties to the books and talk
about where we think things are going so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way thanks for sticking
through the video I've been poor I'll
see you next time take care peace